locus says i could see the forbidden
forest being its own hub world and maybe
even a base for the hypothetical
poachers deeper in the forest i could
see that and think about the trailer
like we see this sort of um well for
lack of a better word dungeon type area
right like there's there's that big
bridge that we see kind of forming and
we see the runes and the characters like
running and then the bridge starts to
form and then there's an area where it
looks like that dragon is being held
captive
if you freeze it right right when it
cuts that shot of the dragon like
breaking free he like he throws his head
back you can see that he's being held
held down by something same thing with
the troll the troll has like chains on
it so maybe there's this dungeon that we
find like hidden deep within hogwarts
underneath hogwarts somewhere where
they're like conducting a lot of this
activity all the new info going back to
the trailer it does look like all the
monsters they showed were probably heard
of enemy cams or dungeons josh i had the
exact same thought i almost want to go
back and like do another video breakdown
of the trailer again like taking all
this new information into account
because there i mean when you think
about dungeons and enemy camps there's a
ton of little things what about
quidditch
i think i think quidditch is in i'll say
90
if you guys didn't see this troy levitt
who
who worked on the game is no longer with
avalanche but he worked on the game and
did an interview with podcast now
another fellow hogwarts like it's a
youtuber the most interesting part of
that whole interview is he's like i get
asked stuff all the time
and almost every time i'm like did you
watch the trailer
did you watch the trailer it's
the trailer it's in the trailer and i
don't know something about when he
talked about that i feel like quidditch
is one of those things because we see
them with the brooms in what appear to
be quidditch robes i think i think that
after him hearing him say that and then
going back yeah i'd be shocked i'd be
really really shocked if quidditch is
not in in some capacity i think that's
the biggest question is like what
capacity is it in is it like can we just
like go and play at any time is like a
separate menu item like it was in the
old games that we have to access do we
just walk down to the quidditch pitch do
we have set story moments
where what if you don't want to join the
quidditch team do you like have to join
the quidditch team or is it an optional
thing you know so all that'll be
interesting how they handle it wonder if
we'll actually be able to read books in
the library i don't know and i wonder
how they're gonna handle learning new
spells because that's like the balance
of like elder scrolls you can literally
like go in and read the books that they
have of course they're not like you know
a full-length book but for a video game
it's like it's a lot of text that you
could scroll through and in the old
games like to learn the spells you know
you didn't you didn't really read
anything it's like you trace the pattern
on the pc game and the other games it's
like here you just you just learn it and
now go and
go and use the spell uh question here
did the photo evidence come from the
original source or the one the pro the
photo evidence came from the second
person i said in my video that another
thing that
made me feel comfortable in in going
with this and reporting it is that
person showed me some photographic i
wouldn't say proof it wasn't like they
showed me a bunch of screenshots of an
enemy camp or something it was nothing
like that some of them were
screenshots of things that have since
already been posted
so we talked a little bit earlier about
the
the gentleman's portfolio that i i don't
even think i can say leaked because they
were publicly available some of the
things i saw were screenshots of that
there was more and the stuff that i
can't show is because the person who
sent these to me
believe that they could possibly get
more information
down the road if it gets out that that
they would know immediately where that
those photos came from and so then they
wouldn't they wouldn't get any other
information at all so that's why i'm not
going to share the pictures yeah but
that was that was probably the biggest
question by far that i saw day nine
cycle wouldn't be surprised if we need
to advance the story to move to the next
season yeah it'll be interesting to see
how they would if they have multiple
seasons how they're going to approach
that because you think about other games
they kind of do it based on location
like the witcher or skyrim for example
it's like you have your snowy area dream
is for a fully dynamic day night season
cycle that progresses naturally would
understand if they did it that way hope
dlcs will take us to other schools
i mean i'd love to see it i think
personally in my opinion i think that's
like if they even attempted something
like that i would i would
i just can't see it sorry miss mystery
mini i just i just can't see that
because that's like just so now dlc
sequels because then like jk rowling has
revealed a lot about the schools
on pottermore but but we don't have that
concrete like like clear visual of every
single one of them so that would give
them a lot of creative freedom
to kind of go crazy with it
a lot of creative freedom if but again i
can't see that in anything but uh but a
sequel
they got it they gotta nail hogwarts in
this game i mean it's called hogwarts
legacy right they got nail hogwarts one
of the reservations people had when they
heard about the game seemingly gonna be
larger than we were thinking is like
oh man does this mean that hogwarts is
gonna be
more like a minor thing you know and
that it's gonna i don't think so no
trust me they know
they know that hogwarts has to be
that has to be of all the settings of
everywhere we go in this game however
many towns and regions and dungeons and
camps that we go to
hogwarts has to be the one
that brings it all together and hot they
have to nail hogwarts before any
anything else so i think i think they
know that hope for a collector's edition
if they don't do a collector's edition
that is a huge missed opportunity
huge missed opportunity i think i think
they know they need a collector's
edition okay radiant dusty had a
question here do you think hogwarts
legacy will be able to be marketed
towards people who have never read harry
potter
maybe even able to bring new fans to
harry potter or do you think you pretty
much need to have
that's a a great question i think this
is definitely going to stand alone i
don't think you'll have to have read
harry potter at all
um it's going to take place
way way way long before that
i think it'll have to be one of those
things where they they make it to where
like they're little references that the
die hard fans are gonna know but i
really think that they will make this a
game that stands on its own to where you
can fully get the story just by jumping
into that do you think it'll come this
year i do think it'll come this year um
the news i'm still not ruling out
another delay
do i dare even say that i know i know
they've said 2022 which they're gonna
say that
they're gonna say that until
they know they may have to delay it
they're gonna say that i do think we
will definitely 100 get news this year
because they've said that and if they
don't then it's like okay now we're
officially worried if we're sitting here
february 2023
and they never gave us anything after
they said in terms of the game hitting
this year
i i've always felt it was going to be a
holiday of this year and even even with
all the september rumors i still even
even if right now internally maybe
they're working toward a september date
i still feel like it gets pushed to
november that's just my guess though
just my guess
what mind delays as long as they keep us
informed even if it's the little things
i made a video a while back this one
didn't get it didn't do nearly as well
as some of the other videos but i was
just like how i would keep the hype
alive it's like we're really not asking
for a lot we're really not it's not like
we need a trailer a month it's like what
if what if tomorrow they just made a
tweet that's like there will be
seven dungeons in hogwarts legacy
in these dungeons you will encounter
and that's it
like just
just that little tease
or just say dungeons you don't have to
put a number on it just give us like a
little tease stuff like that like a
screenshot or two here and there
remember how much we freaked out about
the artwork oh we got a couple questions
here conspiracy theory if you're mr
bossman those people contacted you and
expect to go or part of the market boss
man it it crossed my mind it crossed my
mind especially when expecto go and i
started chatting back and forth in dms
i'm like was this planned it could be if
it is hey
i'm all good with that that's fine with
me uh j ross didn't play tsushima but
the games mentioned seem to talk about
the potential scope of hogwarts legacy
yeah yeah that kind of scope would
explain why they told us they needed a
delay right off the bat in 22 exact yes
and i could not believe i know a lot of
people don't watch all the way through
youtube videos one of the things i
covered toward the end of the video how
have we missed this guys i don't think
i've seen anybody make a comparison
between
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
cover art and hogwarts legacy what we
are guessing is going to be the cover
art but that main wall p wallpaper that
everybody comes back to it's at the very
end of the trailer dude it's like they
literally looked at the zelda box and
are like okay let's make this
with our now that could have just been
an artist thing right you have different
people that work on the art that
probably different people that work on
the actual art inside the game probably
made that
art i have no idea
but i'm like how do we miss this you
know
this they're they were showing us right
here that's the thing that from all this
kind of made me shift my perspective a
little bit is like this is probably
gonna be bigger than i was thinking and
we don't know for sure but from all
those things it sounds like it's gonna
be much bigger i mean multiple regions
right multiple regions you're gonna have
multiple dungeons multiple enemy camps i
mean unless they're all just like
sitting right outside hogwarts which
i don't know maybe forbidden forest like
they could maybe use a little bit of a
creative liberty there and kind of have
a lot of these camps scattered about the
forbidden forest i don't even know if we
know exactly how big the forbidden
forest is uh baller whale says don't
know how i feel about enemy camps being
a core component not the direction i
thought they'd go i'm intrigued though
if you played like um
well something like ghost of tsushima or
even zelda i think it's those things
that are sort of scattered about the
world
to make it feel alive and make it feel
real to where or like like even red dead
redemption or something you know you
don't want to just go
at least i don't when i'm playing an
open world game i don't want to just go
from point a to point b
here's your mission okay i go and do it
here's your next mission okay i go and
do it what really makes those worlds
feel alive is like when you're when
you're starting off on that mission
and then you see like
wait what the heck there's these goblins
over here and they're like fighting
these centaurs what what or or look at
this there's this uh
there's like there's a half giant over
there crying out in pain now this is now
that none of this is like any of the
information i've seen i'm just like
spitballing with you guys here
and then you're like you feel compelled
to like branch off your path and go
investigate and that's what i'm hoping
these camps are like if you think about
breath of the wild if you played breath
of the wild man it's such a good game
for so many reasons it wasn't
everybody's cup of tea but the vast
majority of people love that game but
when you're playing that game you're
just like all of a sudden you like
notice something going on over here it's
like wait what are these enemies doing
what's going on these guys are like
patrolling around this
what and then and then you like go and
you you complete that little area and
then you find there was actually like
some items there that you're able to
collect and use so things like that i
think that's really what the enemy camps
are gonna be used for but uh as always
thank you all so much for watching and i
will talk to you again
soon